This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The turn of the year is a time when we set the old aside and welcome the new into our lives. And so today we bring you a tale of loss and renewal from December 2015. It appeals to me for two reasons. The first is it's a universal story. I was really devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about and that had really constituted such a large part of my life and my identity. You know, I was first and foremost a violinist. The second reason is that this is also about social science research and its applications in the real world. What we found was a 9% increase in college enrollment rates.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。岁末年初是一个我们将旧事抛诸脑后、迎来生命中新事物的时刻。因此，今天我们为您带来一个2015年12月关于失去与重生的故事。这个故事吸引我原因有二。首先，这是一个普遍的故事。我当时因为失去了一件我深爱且充满热情的事物而感到无比崩溃，这曾构成了我生命和身份中如此重要的一部分。你知道的，我首先是一名小提琴手。第二个原因则是，这也关乎社会科学研究及其在现实世界中的应用。我们发现大学入学率提高了9%。
As a result of 8 text messages. I mean that is really profound. 8 text messages is what I send my best friend on any given day. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Today we're telling you a story that begins in the attic of a home in Connecticut and ends at the White House. And on our theme of loss and reinvention, we'll bring you a poem I came across
仅仅由于8条短信。我的意思是这真的非常深刻。8条短信正是我在任何一天发给我最好的朋友的短信数量。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们为您讲述一个始于康涅狄格州一栋房子的阁楼、终于白宫的故事。顺着我们关于失去与重生的主题，我们将为您带来一首我偶然读到的诗
from Elizabeth Bishop, read by musician Amy Mann. Then practice losing farther, losing faster, places and names and where it was you meant to travel. None of these will bring disaster. My grandmother was an Indian classical violinist and so my mom had her old violin and arctic for many years. This is Maya Shankar, no relation. Each of my three older siblings had rejected the violin saying that it wasn't cool enough and my mom finally gave me the instrument and I was immediately taken kind of by the tactile sensation
作者是伊丽莎白·毕晓普，由音乐家艾米·曼恩朗读。然后练习失去得更远，失去得更快，地方、名字以及你原本打算去旅行的地方。这些都不会带来灾难。我的祖母是一位印度古典小提琴手，所以我妈妈多年来一直把她旧的小提琴收在阁楼里。我是玛雅·尚卡尔，没有亲戚关系。我的三个哥哥姐姐都曾拒绝过这把小提琴，说它不够酷，我妈妈最终把这把乐器交给了我，我立刻就被它那种触觉般的感受所吸引
of the instrument. I mean, the wood and the bow. I just loved the feeling of playing the violin. Even as a child, Maya immediately loved everything about the violin. The way it looked, the way it felt, the way it sounded. Maya's mother didn't know much about Western classical music, but she signed up her daughter for lessons using the Suzuki method. The focus was on playing by
这种乐器的质感。我是说，木头和琴弓。我就是喜欢拉小提琴的感觉。即使在孩童时期，玛雅也立刻爱上了小提琴的一切。它的外观，它的触感，它的声音。玛雅的母亲对西方古典音乐知之甚少，但她用铃木教学法为女儿报名了小提琴课。这个方法侧重于通过
ear and making beautiful sound. Maya practiced constantly. I had a special scheduled school to lump all my classes together so that I come a little bit early and get a little bit more practice in, and especially with all the traveling, most days were devoted exclusively to music. She got good, very good. Now the part of her musical education that was missing was the formal part. She didn't know how to read music very well, but she had a fine ear and she had ambition. In the pursuit to find a teacher who would take her to the next level, Maya's mother did something quite daring.
耳朵去聆听并发出美妙的声音。玛雅一直在练习。我在学校有一个特殊的日程安排，把所有课程集中在一起，这样我可以早点去上课并多练习一会儿，尤其是伴随着各种奔波，大多数日子基本上完全奉献给了音乐。她进步很快，非常快。现在，她音乐教育中唯一缺少的是正规的部分。她不太会识谱，但她有着敏锐的耳朵和雄心壮志。为了寻找一位能带她进入更高水平的老师，玛雅的母亲做了一件非常大胆的事。
Yeah, so my mom, she was really a go-getter when it came to my violin life because, like I said, she didn't really have a lot of experience or exposure to the music community and kind of had to innovate in order to find opportunities. There were a New York one day close to the Juilliard school, one of the world's most famous and exclusive music institutions, when her mother came up with an idea, she said, Why don't we just go to Juilliard? I mean, why not? Right, what can we lose?
是的，所以当我谈到我的小提琴生涯时，我妈妈真的是个行动派，因为就像我说的，她其实并没有太多音乐界的经验或接触，为了寻找机会不得不进行创新。有一天在纽约，靠近朱莉亚音乐学院——世界上最著名和最排他的音乐机构之一时，她妈妈冒出了一个想法，她说：“我们为什么不直接去朱莉亚呢？我是说，为什么不呢？对吧，我们有什么可失去的？”
Just walk in the door. We just walked in. So we walked into the building, and just by happenstance, we happen to run into a student in the elevator who studied with a music teacher, and my mom talked to that family and the elevator and said, would you mind if we just had about five or ten minutes at the end of your lesson where Maya could play for your teacher?
直接走进去。我们真的就走进去了。于是我们走进了大楼，非常巧合的是，我们在电梯里碰巧遇到了一位学生，他正跟随一位音乐老师学习，我妈妈就在电梯里和那个家庭交谈，并说：“你们介不介意在你们上完课的最后留出五到十分钟，让玛雅为你们的老师演奏一次呢？”
And they were really gracious and they said, sure, no problem. Of course, you know what happened next. Maya played for the other students' music teacher, wild the teacher, and got accepted into a summer program. Soon she was taking classes at Juilliard. She was playing with other talented musicians. She was even being featured on NPR. Joining us now is the Juilliard pre-college violin quartet.
他们非常亲切地说：“当然，没问题。”当然，你知道接下来发生了什么。玛雅为其他学生的音乐老师演奏了，惊艳了这位老师，并被录取进入一个暑期项目。很快她就开始在朱莉亚上课了。她与其他极具才华的音乐家一起演奏。她甚至还登上了美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）的节目。现在加入我们的是朱莉亚预科小提琴四重奏。
They are 17-year-old Emily Gendron from Glassenberg, Connecticut. 15-year-old Maya Shankar from Cheshire, Connecticut. Maya, by the way, is a from-the-top veteran. She's been with us since the early 50s. That was Maya on NPR's from the top. She had found her classical music home. She was talented, hard-working, and the path before her seemed clear. I really wanted to be a violinist. I was so passionate about it. I never felt more comfortable than when I was performing. For some reason, that's where I experienced flow.
他们是来自康涅狄格州格拉斯森堡的17岁女孩埃米莉·热德龙。来自康涅狄格州柴郡的15岁女孩玛雅·尚卡尔。顺便说一句，玛雅是NPR节目《巅峰起点》的常客。她从50年代初就一直和我们在一起。那是玛雅在NPR的《巅峰起点》节目中的表现。她找到了她的古典音乐归宿。她很有天赋，工作努力，她面前的道路似乎清晰明了。我真的很想成为一名小提琴手。我对它充满了热情。当我表演时，我从未感到如此自在。出于某种原因，那就是我体验到心流的地方。
And, you know, the ability to spend a lot of time, you know, practicing and trying to perfect the art. And then you go on stage and you kind of just surrender. And, you know, you play to the best of your abilities. There's just something beautiful and elegant about that process, and I just really, really loved it. ["The Little One"] She was so good and so enthusiastic that opportunities kept presenting themselves. One day, her teacher at Juliet arranged for her to play for a famous violinist,
而且，你知道的，那种能够花大量时间去练习并试图完善这门艺术的能力。然后你走上舞台，你基本上就是顺其自然。而且，你知道的，你尽你最大的能力去演奏。这个过程有一种美丽而优雅的东西，我真的、真的非常喜欢它。《小家伙》她是如此优秀且充满热情，以至于机会不断向她涌来。有一天，她在朱莉亚的老师安排她为一位著名的小提琴家演奏，
a very famous violinist. I nearly fell over in my seat because no reasonable musician thinks they're going to get the opportunity to meet its octaulman, let alone play for its octaulman. Do you remember what you played? I played the Barber violin concert, played the first movement. The PURLMAN decided to take her on as a student. In addition to Saturdays, I was also going to New York multiple times during the week, either for studio classes at his home in Manhattan or for private lessons or chamber music lessons. And at that point, it was very clear to me that I wanted to become a concert violinist. Well, I remember that she sounded, she had a very lovely, we're making music.
一位非常著名的小提琴家。我差一点从座位上摔下来，因为没有哪个理智的音乐家会认为自己有机会见到伊扎克·帕尔曼，更不用说为伊扎克·帕尔曼演奏了。你还记得你当时拉的是什么吗？我拉的是巴伯小提琴协奏曲，拉了第一乐章。帕尔曼决定收她为学生。除了星期六，我每周还要去纽约好几次，要么去他在曼哈顿家中的工作室上课，要么去上私教课或室内乐课。在那个时候，我非常清楚地知道，我想成为一名音乐会小提琴家。嗯，我记得她听起来，她有一种非常可爱的，我们在创作音乐。
And that's for me, it resues the most important thing. To concert violinist Itzak Pearlman, it was okay that Maya had learned to play music by ear rather than by reading music. The technical stuff was important, but it could be learned. You know, it's more important for me to have somebody musical. And let's say that the technique wise has, you know, you have to work on the technique, but the important thing is the music. And I felt that you had a very lovely way of phrasing and so on and so forth. And so we worked on that, but then we also worked on, you know, how do you accomplish
对我来说，这被认为是件最重要的事情。对于音乐会小提琴家伊扎克·帕尔曼来说，玛雅是通过听觉而不是通过识谱来学习音乐，这是可以接受的。技术方面的东西很重要，但它是可以被学会的。你知道的，对我来说更重要的是找一个有音乐感的人。比方说技术方面，你知道的，你必须在技术上下功夫，但重要的是音乐。我觉得你有一种非常可爱的分句方式等等。所以我们在这方面下了功夫，但我们也研究了，你知道的，你如何从技术上完成
technically certain things, for example, in the barboard concert, a little lost movement, there's a little bit tricky. So how do you practice that? But Perlman didn't just teach Maya how to play the violin. He taught her something much more important. How to teach herself to play the violin. I remember lots of lessons were, instead of telling me, Maya, OK, clearly you're unsatisfied with that phrase. Here's what you should do to make it better.
某些事情，例如在巴伯协奏曲中，末乐章有点棘手。那么你如何练习这个呢？但帕尔曼不仅教玛雅如何拉小提琴。他教了她更重要的东西。如何自学拉小提琴。我记得有很多次课，他并没有直接告诉我：“玛雅，好吧，显然你对那个乐句不满意。你应该这样做来把它拉得更好。”
He would instead say, Maya, clearly are unsatisfied with that phrase, what do you think you should do in order to make that phrase better? Let's talk about it. Let me hear what your aspirations are for the arc of this musical phrase. What tools do you have at your disposal, either with your bow arm or your vibrato or your tone, in order to make it beautiful? And it's really frustrating.
相反，他会说：“玛雅，显然你对那个乐句不满意，你认为为了让那个乐句更好，你应该做些什么呢？我们来谈谈吧。让我听听你对这个音乐乐句走向的期望是什么。你手头有什么工具，无论是你的弓臂、揉弦还是音色，能让它变得优美？”这真的很令人沮丧。
I mean, in the moment you're thinking, okay, man, like you're the expert here, you know? Just tell me what to do. Just tell me what to do. Just tell me what to do and make this easier for both of us. So the more you learn, the more to think for yourself, and to try and solve problems on your own, the better it is for you for the future. It was all going so well.
我的意思是，当时你会想：“好吧，帕尔曼，这里你是专家，你知道吗？直接告诉我该怎么做。直接告诉我该怎么做。直接告诉我该怎么做，让咱们两个都轻松点。”所以你学到的越多，你就越能独立思考，并尝试自己解决问题，这对你的未来就越好。一切都进展得如此顺利。
When Maya was 15, she was practicing at a program run by its sock parliament. And I was playing a passage from a very challenging Paganini Caprice. And I simply overstretched my finger on one note and I felt kind of a popping. And so I overstretched the tendon and it didn't really heal as expected. And so how did you spend the next months? What did you do? Well Mr. Prolman was such a gem because I injured my left hand. He continued to teach me violin just with my bow arm.
当玛雅15岁时，她在伊扎克·帕尔曼开办的一个项目里练习。当时我正在练习帕格尼尼随想曲中一个非常具有挑战性的乐段。我只是在一个音符上过度伸展了手指，然后我听到了一种像是弹响的声音。于是我过度拉伸了肌腱，它并没有像预期那样愈合。那么你是怎么度过接下来的几个月的？你做了什么？哦，帕尔曼先生真是一个大好人，因为我的左手受伤了。他继续教我拉小提琴，只是用我的弓臂。
So for over a year, I went to him and we just worked on perfecting my bow arm and I would just play open strings in every lesson and he would teach me about how to produce a beautiful sound. You know, you always feel that it will resolve itself, so usually what happens if one hand doesn't particularly respond or anything like this, you work on the other hand, just not to waste time, just to do so if you've got your left hand, there's a problem that you work on the right hand advice of hers.
所以在一年多的时间里，我去他那里，我们就只是致力于完善我的弓臂，我在每节课上都只拉空弦，他会教我如何发出美妙的声音。你知道的，你总是觉得情况会自行解决，所以通常发生的情况是，如果一只手没有特别的反应或者出现类似情况，你就会锻炼另一手，这样就不会浪费时间，只要去做就行了。如果你左手有问题，你就按照他的建议去锻炼右手。
It's good, you know, her attitude was, you know, I mean, obviously she wasn't, I mean, I'm sure that she was feeling good about it, but it was never like what's to use. Maya's hand didn't heal. Doctors finally told her she had to stop playing completely. I was really devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about, and that had really constituted such a large part of my life and my identity.
这很好，你知道的，她的态度是，你知道的，我的意思是，很显然她并不是，我的意思是，我确信她当时感觉挺好，但她从没有表现得像是“这有什么用”。玛雅的手没有好转。医生最终告诉她，她必须完全停止演奏。我当时因为失去了一件我深爱且充满热情的事物而感到无比崩溃，这曾构成了我生命和身份中如此重要的一部分。
I was first and foremost a violinist. And so I was anxious because I was worried that I would never find something that I felt as passionately about as I did with music. Just like that, Maya's dream to become a concert violinist was over. Just like that, Maya's dream to become a concert violinist was over. Back home for the summer in Connecticut, she started to ask herself how she could pick up the pieces, which she ever find anything that could make her as happy as the violin. Our next guest appeared as a violinist on a pilot episode when she was just 12 years old.
我首先是一名小提琴手。因此我感到焦虑，因为我担心我再也找不到像音乐那样让我充满热情的事务了。就这样，玛雅成为音乐会小提琴手的梦想破灭了。就这样，玛雅成为音乐会小提琴手的梦想破灭了。回到康涅狄格州过暑假时，她开始问自己该如何收拾残局，她是否还能找到任何能让她像拉小提琴那样快乐的东西。我们的下一位嘉宾在12岁时就以小提琴手的身份出现在试播集中。
She's now 23 and during those intervening years, well, brace yourself because what she's accomplished is a little humbling to us mere mortals. Please welcome Maya Shankar. To find out what Maya did, stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. On our last podcast of the year, we're exploring the idea of closing the book on one chapter of your life and opening another. We're doing it through the story of Maya Shankar. After learning she could no longer play the violin due to an injury to her left hand,
她现在23岁了，在过去的那些年里，好吧，请做好心理准备，因为她所取得的成就让我们这些凡人感到有些相形见绌。请欢迎玛雅·尚卡尔。想知道玛雅做了什么，请继续收听我们节目。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我们今年的最后一期播客中，我们将探讨合上人生某一章节并开启另一章节的想法。我们将通过玛雅·尚卡尔的故事来探讨这一点。在得知由于左手受伤而无法继续拉小提琴后，
Maya retreated to her parents' home in Connecticut. Her life felt indizere. The summer before, doctors basically told me I had to stop playing completely. And just by luck, I was helping my parents clean their basement in Cheshire, Connecticut. And I stumbled upon an old coursebook of my sisters. It was called The Language Instinct by Stephen Pinker.
玛雅退守到她父母在康涅狄格州的家中。她的生活感觉暗淡无光。前一个夏天，医生基本上告诉我必须完全停止演奏。而就在机缘巧合下，我在康涅狄格州柴郡帮父母清理地下室。我偶然翻到了一本我姐姐的旧教科书。这本书叫斯蒂芬·平克的《语言本能》。
Maya started reading, and the more she read, the more excited she became. It was remarkable for me to learn about just how complex our minds were and just what was required in order for us to have our day-to-day experiences. And so it really went my appetite for learning more about the mind and for exploring and more depth, kind of the brilliance of the brain. She started to study cognitive science. She went on to get her PhD at Oxford on a Rhodes scholarship. She got a postdoctoral fellowship, a promising career in academia, Leia Headifur. But here again, came another unexpected turn. So, over Thanksgiving break of the final year of my postdoc, I was at home and I was visiting my undergraduate advisor from college, named Laurie Santos, and she was telling me about the U.S. Department of Agriculture's
玛雅开始阅读，她读得越多，就越兴奋。了解我们的思维是多么的复杂，以及我们需要什么才能拥有日常的种种体验，这对我来说非常了不起。因此，这确实激起了我想要更多地了解思维、并更深入地探索大脑之精妙的胃口。她开始学习认知科学。后来她凭借罗德奖学金在牛津大学获得了博士学位。她获得了博士后研究奖学金，在学术界有着前途无量的职业生涯。但是在这里，又发生了一个意想不到的转折。所以，在我博士后最后一年的感恩节假期里，我在家拜访了我在大学时的本科导师洛里·桑托斯，她正在向我讲述美国农业部的
efforts to get free and reduced price lunches, school lunches, into the hands of more eligible students. Students were going hungry because the process of getting certified for the lunch program was cumbersome. The Department of Agriculture came up with a simple idea. Instead of having a multi-step sign-up system, states could use information they already had about poor families to help enroll children in the lunch program. And it's just a matter of data matching and cross-enrolling these students.
努力，旨在将免费和减价午餐——学校午餐，送到更多符合资格的学生手中。学生们正在挨饿，因为获得午餐项目认证的过程非常繁琐。农业部想出了一个简单的点子。各州无需采用多步骤的注册系统，而是可以使用他们已经掌握的关于贫困家庭的信息，来帮助儿童注册午餐项目。这其实只是一个数据匹配和让这些学生跨项目注册的问题。
But as a result of this common sense reform, you know, 12.4 million students, as of 2015, were automatically enrolled into the school lunch program and had access to lunches and were able to thrive at school. And I remember being so moved by this example. To Maya, it was magical. It was just like a light bulb went off in my head, and I thought, okay, this is what I need to be doing with my life.
但由于这项常识性的改革，你知道，截至2015年，有1240万学生被自动注册到了学校午餐项目中，并获得了午餐，能够在学校里茁壮成长。我记得我被这个例子深深地感动了。对玛雅来说，这简直太神奇了。这就像我的脑海里亮起了一盏灯，我想，好吧，这就是我一生中需要去做的事情。
I want to be taking research insights from the behavioral sciences and allowing them to find their way into public policy so that they can be in the service of Americans and people around the world. So how do you break into the world of policy when you're just a lowly postdoc? Maya knew nothing of politics. She didn't have connections in the world of government. But she did remember a lesson her mother had taught her, standing outside the Juilliard school years earlier.
我想将行为科学的研究成果引入公共政策中，让它们服务于美国人和世界各地的人们。那么，当你只是一个低微的博士后时，如何才能涉足政策领域呢？玛雅对政治一无所知。她在政府圈子里没有任何人脉。但她确实记得母亲多年前在朱莉亚音乐学院门外教给她的一个教训。
She tracked down an email address for Thomas Kalea, who was helping the Obama administration with its science policy. I sent Tom again a cold email. This is the Juilliard method again. This is my mom's dueler. I get to give her full credit for this. She is totally fearless and kind of inspired this trait. And I went over to his home and he asked me to pitch to him ideas that I had around interventions where behavioral science could improve public policy outcomes.
她找到了托马斯·卡利（Thomas Kalea）的电子邮箱地址，他当时正在协助奥巴马政府推进科学政策。我又给汤姆发了一封冷邮件。这又是朱莉亚方法。这是我妈妈的朱莉亚方法。我得把全部功劳归功于她。她完全无所畏惧，某种程度上激发了我身上这种特质。我去了他家，他让我向他推介我关于干预措施的想法，这些干预利用行为科学来改善公共政策的结果。
What do you tell him? I talked to him about a number of things like the importance of using social norms to where behavioral science could improve public policy outcomes. What are you telling them? I talked to him about a number of things, like the importance of using social norms to motivate behavior. So we know from research that if you tell people that their neighbors use less energy than they do, they're more likely to use less energy. And there's a lot of domains in which just telling people
你跟他说了什么？我跟他谈了很多事情，比如利用社会规范来改善公共政策结果的重要性。你跟他们说什么？我跟他谈了很多事情，比如利用社会规范来激励行为的重要性。所以我们从研究中得知，如果你告诉人们他们的邻居比他们消耗更少的能量，他们就更有可能消耗更少的能量。而且在许多领域，仅仅是告诉人们
what the data shows about people's actions and decisions can actually drive actions that are more in alignment with people's long-term goals or with policy objectives. And something that struck me about that conversation is I have been talking for years with my academic colleagues about the potential applications of using behavioral insights to improve people's lives. And this was the first time that when I told him an idea that I had, his response was,
关于人们行动和决策的数据显示什么，实际上就可以推动那些更符合人们长期目标或政策目标的行动。那次对话中让我印象深刻的是，多年来我一直与学术界的同事们讨论将行为洞察力应用于改善人们生活的潜力。而这是我第一次向他讲述我的一个想法时，他的回应是：
oh, we can find a way to do that. Maya joined the White House. She was asked to put together a team that could marshal ideas from social science research and apply them to public policy challenges. You've had a chance in your current role to actually work on this project that started you on this mission, the school lunch program. Can you tell me a little bit about that? So we have been working with the U.S. Department of Agriculture and also local school districts
哦，我们可以找到办法做到这一点。玛雅加入了白宫。她被要求组建一个团队，将社会科学研究的理念整理出来，并将其应用到公共政策的挑战中。在你目前的职位上，你曾有机会实际参与这个让你走上这项使命的项目，即学校午餐项目。你能跟我多讲讲那个项目吗？因此，我们一直在与美国农业部以及地方学区合作
to redesign communications that they're sending to families to help promote the verification process so that their kids can stay on the benefit. So we've done a few things. So there's a few behavioral insights that we've used. One is we've taken a very long list of action steps required for verification and condense them into three easy to understand steps that you can take. Two, we've worked with school districts to translate the communications into multiple languages in order to support comprehension
来重新设计他们发给家庭的通知，以帮助推动核实流程，从而使他们的孩子能够继续享受福利。所以我们做了几件事。我们使用了一些行为洞察。第一，我们将长长的一串核实所需的行动步骤，精简为你可以采取的三个易于理解的步骤。第二，我们与学区合作，将通知翻译成多种语言，以支持该项目服务的多元化人群中的
among the diverse population that this program serves. One issue is that at present, families might only think the way to recertify or to verify their information is to send snail mail back to the school district. And instead, there's the opportunity for them to take a picture of their information using their mobile phones and actually email it back.
理解能力。一个问题是，目前，家庭可能只认为重新认证或核实他们信息的途径是将纸质信件寄回学区。而实际上，他们有机会使用手机拍摄他们信息的照片，并通过电子邮件发回来。
And we simply notified people of the opportunity to go through that process. And then in other instances, we included prepaid envelopes to help ease the process of verifying eligibility. I'm trying to think about why it is we often have trouble thinking about programs like this, because as someone who has been interested in human behavior for a while, it seems to me that programs like these really are no pun intended, no brainer, that this is really something that we should be doing. It seems obvious that we should be doing it. But I think part of the issue is that I think many people
我们只是通知人们可以通过该流程进行操作。然后，在其他情况下，我们附上了预付邮资的信封，以帮助简化核实资格的流程。我在思考为什么我们经常很难考虑这样的项目，因为作为一个长期对人类行为感兴趣的人，在我看来，这样的项目真的——双关语，不用动脑子——这确实是我们应该做的事情。我们应该去做这件事，这似乎是显而易见的。但我认为部分问题在于，我认为许多人
might say, if you want to stay in a program that's giving you benefits, and these are the steps you need to do in order to get the benefits, and you deserve those benefits, rationally speaking, you should be willing to do those steps in order to get the benefits. And I think it fails to take into account the difference between how human beings are supposed to behave as rational creatures and how they actually behave.
可能会说，如果你想留在一个为你提供福利的项目中，而这些是你获得福利所需要做的步骤，并且你应得这些福利，那么从理性上讲，你应该愿意为了获得福利而采取这些步骤。我认为这未能考虑到理性的生物应该如何行为与他们实际行为之间的差异。
And I feel like that's the central divide that your work is trying to bridge. And I think additionally, you know, the onus is on the government to present information clearly, to present choices clearly, so that people understand what program exists and what their options are and can make the best decisions for themselves and their families. But there's one example that I wanted to point to, which is a phenomenon known as summer melt. This is the phenomenon where talented high school students who are on track to go to college at the start of the summer somehow lose their way and don't show up at college in the fall. Maya and her team have worked on simple, low-cost interventions
我觉得这就是你的工作试图弥合的核心鸿沟。我认为此外，你知道的，政府有责任清晰地呈现信息、清晰地呈现选择，以便人们了解存在什么项目以及他们的选择是什么，并为自己和家人做出最佳决策。但我想指出一个例子，那就是被称为“夏季流失”的现象。这是一种现象，即那些在夏天开始时有望上大学的优秀高中生，不知怎么地迷失了方向，到了秋天却没有出现在大学里。玛雅和她的团队致力于研究简单、低成本的干预措施
that can help these students get to college. Their idea send the students eight text messages over the summer, reminding them of impending deadlines. What we found was a 9% increase in college enrollment rates. As a result of eight text messages, I mean that is really profound. Eight text messages is what I send my best friend on any given day. It seems to me that what you did and what happened to you is actually happens to lots of people all the time where doors close and they feel like it's unbearable
可以帮助这些学生上大学。他们的想法是在夏天给学生发八条短信，提醒他们即将到来的截止日期。我们发现大学入学率提高了9%。由于八条短信，我的意思是这真的很深刻。八条短信正是我在任何一天发给我最好的朋友的短信数量。在我看来，你所做的事以及你身上发生的事，实际上一直在许多人身上发生：大门关闭了，他们觉得这扇门关闭是无法忍受的，因为这就是我以为我生活的地方。然后另一扇门打开了，你意识到实际上有很多很多我们可以栖居的房子。
that this door is closed because this is where I thought I lived. And then another door opens and you realize there are actually many many houses in which we can live. I think that's exactly right. And I think you know one thing that violin, one of the great blessings of playing the violin is that it allowed me to see what it really felt like to be in love with something and to be really passionate about something. And so if anything, you see sort of features or traits that are extracted in you from engaging with that pursuit.
我想完全正确。而且我认为你知道，拉小提琴的一点，拉小提琴的一大幸事在于，它让我看到了真正爱上某件事并对某件事充满热情是什么感觉。所以如果非要说有什么的话，你可以看到从参与这项追求中在你身上提取出来的某种特征或特质。
And then your hope is that in the new explorations, those disciplines or those areas can extract those same qualities from you. I'm wondering, as you think about your own life, do you feel that your career now has been set? This is the house you're going to live in forever? Do you actually believe, on the other hand, that there might be many other houses you will one day come to live in?
然后你的希望是，在新的探索中，这些学科或这些领域能够从你身上提取出相同的品质。我在想，当你思考自己的人生时，你是否觉得你的职业生涯现在已经定型了？这就是你将永远居住的房子？另一方面，你是否真的相信，未来某天你可能会住进许多其他的房子？
Well, certainly never been happier than I am right now, working in public service and using my background to help improve people's lives. So I think that that will continue to be a common theme of whatever it is that I end up doing and working in. That said, I think there are so many ways in which that passion can manifest, right? And I think that one thing the past has taught me is that the world has endless opportunities to positively impact people's lives.
嗯，我当然从未比现在更快乐过，从事公共服务并利用我的背景来帮助改善人们的生活。所以我认为这将继续成为我最终从事和工作的任何事情的共同主题。话虽如此，我认为这种激情可以通过多种方式表现出来，对吧？我认为过去教给我的一件事是，世界有无限的机会来对人们的生活产生积极的影响。
And along the way, I might explore various different paths in order to get there, but as long as I stick to that core value of trying to help people and improve people's lives, I think that there are many ways to do that. And of course, you have the cold-called Julia Admeta to aid you. Yeah, so I think that, yeah again, thanks to my mom, I think that there is always that full-proof method of the standard cold-call. That was Maya Shankar. She served as Senior Advisor for the Social and Behavioral Sciences at the White House Office
在这个过程中，我可能会探索各种不同的道路来实现这一目标，但只要我坚持试图帮助人们和改善人们生活这一核心价值观，我认为有很多方法可以做到这一点。当然，你还有冷邮件朱莉亚方法来帮助你。是的，所以我想，再次感谢我妈妈，我认为标准冷邮件的那种万无一失的方法永远存在。那是玛雅·尚卡尔。她曾在奥巴马总统任内的白宫科学与技术政策办公室担任社会与行为科学高级顾问。
of Science and Technology Policy under President Obama. Since then, Maya has left the White House and become Google's first head of behavioral insights. I told you at the start of this episode that Maya's story is a universal story. Now, not all of us are going to be concert via Linus or Rhodes Scholars or presidential advisors, but I don't think any of those things are the real point of Maya's story. Now, not all of us are going to be concert violinists or road scholars or presidential advisers, but I don't think any of those things are the real point of Maya's story. The reason I wanted to tell you the story, at the turn of a new year, is because all of us have chapters in our lives that close, and when they do, especially if it's a chapter we have known and loved for a long time, it can feel like the whole book is over, that
自那以后，玛雅离开了白宫，成为了谷歌的第一任行为洞察负责人。我在本集节目开始时告诉过你，玛雅的故事是一个普遍的故事。现在，我们并非所有人都能成为音乐会小提琴手、罗德学者或总统顾问，但我认为这些都不是玛雅故事真正的重点。现在，我们并非所有人都能成为音乐会小提琴手、罗德学者或总统顾问，但我认为这些都不是玛雅故事真正的重点。我之所以想在新年伊始给你讲这个故事，是因为我们每个人的生活中都有合上的章节，当它们合上时，尤其是如果这是一个我们熟悉并爱了很长时间的章节，就会让人觉得整本书都结束了，
there's nothing left to do, maybe even nothing left to live for. But I think each of us has stories in our lives that reflect the fact that the people we are today are not the same people we were a few years ago. We often underestimate our capacity to reinvent ourselves. I was talking some years ago with Rick Pots. He's a paleoanthropologist and the head of the Smithsonian Institution's Human Origins Program. And something he said stuck in my head. He told me that the thing that distinguished early humans from other species was our remarkable
可能觉得无事可做，甚至觉得生无可恋。但我认为我们每个人生活中的故事都反映出这样一个事实：今天的我们已经不再是几年前的我们了。我们常常低估了自己重新塑造自我的能力。几年前我曾与里克·波茨交谈过。他是一位古人类学家，也是史密森尼学会人类起源项目的负责人。他说的一句话一直留在我脑海里。他告诉我，早期人类与其他物种的区别在于我们非凡的
capacity to adapt to different conditions, different situations. Uniquely, humans live in very cold places and very hot places, at altitude and sea level, some of us live long periods underwater or even in outer space. Most of that isn't about our physical abilities, it's really about the mind. And each year, around this time, we need to remind ourselves that as one door closes, we have the ability to find other doors to open. I want to leave you with a lovely poem by Elizabeth Bishop. Singer Amy Mann happened to be at NPR and we asked her to read the poem for us.
适应不同条件、不同情境的能力。人类独一无二地生活在非常寒冷和非常炎热的地方、高海拔和海平面，我们中的一些人还在水下甚至太空中度过很长时间。这大部分不关乎我们的身体能力，真正关乎的是大脑。每年这个时候，我们都需要提醒自己，当一扇门关闭时，我们有能力找到其他门去打开。我想用伊丽莎白·毕晓普的一首可爱的诗来结束今天的节目。歌手艾米·曼恩碰巧在NPR，我们请她为我们朗读了这首诗。
One art by Elizabeth Bishop. The art of losing isn't hard to master. So many things seem filled with the intent to be lost, that their loss is no disaster. Lose something every day, except the fluster of lost dorkies, the hour badly spent, the art of losing isn't hard to master. Then practice losing farther, losing faster, places and names and where it was you meant to travel. None of these will bring disaster.
伊丽莎白·毕晓普的《一门艺术》。失去的艺术并不难掌握。许多事情似乎都充满了要失去的意图，以至于它们的失去并非灾难。每天失去一些东西，除了那些慌乱——失去钥匙、虚度光阴——失去的艺术并不难掌握。然后练习失去得更远，失去更快，地方、名字以及你原本打算去旅行的地方。这些都不会带来灾难。
I lost my mother's watch. And look, my last or next to last of three loved houses went. The art of losing isn't hard to master. I lost two cities' lovely ones, and Vastor, some realms I owned, two rivers a continent. I missed them, but it wasn't a disaster. Even losing you, the joking voice suggests your I love. I shant have lied. It's evident the art of losing is not too hard to master, though it may look like, write it, like disaster. That was Amy Mann, reading one art by Elizabeth Bishop. Amy was at NPR with Ted Leo to perform for the All Songs Considered Podcast. This episode was produced by Maggie Penman and Karamagar Galasin.
我弄丢了我母亲的手表。看吧，我三个心爱的房子中的最后几个也接连离去。失去的艺术并不难掌握。我失去了两座可爱的城市，还有广阔的领域，我曾拥有的某些王国，两条河流，一个大洲。我怀念它们，但这并不是灾难。甚至失去你——那句开玩笑的话暗示着你的“我爱你”——我也并未说谎。显然，失去的艺术并不算太难掌握，尽管它看起来——写下来吧——就像是一场灾难。那是艾米·曼恩朗读的伊丽莎白·毕晓普的《一门艺术》。艾米当时和泰德·莱奥一起在NPR为《所有歌曲》播客节目进行表演。本集由玛吉·彭南和卡拉马加·加拉辛制作。
Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah, Raina Cohen, Laura Correll, Tara Boyle, Thomas Liu and Kemela Vargas Chrestrepo. Our unsung hero this week is someone who helped me reinvent my own life. Paul Ginsburg is a longtime NPR supporter and donor. In December 2013, Paul came to me and told me I should be doing more than just weekly stories for radio. What about a podcast he asked? Paul did more than just simply toss out an idea. He helped to make it a reality.
我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、帕特·沙阿、雷娜·科恩、劳拉·科雷尔、塔拉·博伊尔、托马斯·刘和凯梅拉·瓦尔加斯·克雷斯特雷波。我们本周的无名英雄是一位帮助我重塑自己生活的人。保罗·金斯伯格是NPR的长期支持者和捐赠者。2013年12月，保罗找到我，告诉我我不应该只为电台做每周的故事。他问：“做个播客怎么样？”保罗做的不仅仅是随口抛出一个想法。他帮助将其变成了现实。
He raised funds to launch Hidden Brain and he's been a trusted friend and advisor ever since. More than time and money, Paul gave me what might be the most valuable gift one person can give another. He helped me see something in myself that I had not seen on my own. Thanks Paul. From everyone at Hidden Brain, we wish you new paths, new dreams, and much reinvention this coming year. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他筹集资金启动了《隐藏的大脑》，从那以后他一直是我值得信赖的朋友和顾问。比起时间和金钱，保罗给予我可能是一个人能给另一个的最宝贵的礼物。他帮我在自己身上看到了一些我没有独自发现的东西。谢谢你，保罗。来自《隐藏的大脑》的全体同仁，祝愿您在新的一年里有新的道路、新的梦想以及许多重塑自我的机会。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。